hello and welcome to Sophie Ridge on
Sunday I think it's just about okay to
still be saying happy new year at this
point and we've got a very special
program to start 2023 because we're
going to be bringing you the exclusive
first look at a special Sky News
investigation into the money that MPS
get from donations gifts and outside
earnings that's been 10 months in the
making it shines a light of money in
Westminster and poses important
questions about influence in our
politics and we'll also bring you an
exclusive interview with a man that all
the polls say will be the next prime
minister of this country
so in just a moment we're going to bring
you that exclusive reports and then
we'll speak live to the man who wants to
be the next prime minister and if the
polls are correct he will be that is the
labor leader of the opposition
with the NHS facing unprecedented
challenges from nurse and Doctor strikes
to huge backlogs and Emergency Care
seemingly on the brink of collapse for
the government will be joined by Health
Minister and nurse herself Maria
Caufield
and we'll try and find out just how bad
things really are on the front line of
the NHS with the president of the Royal
College of emergency medicine Dr Adrian
Boyle who met the prime minister at
number 10 just yesterday
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s MPS have wrestled with a relationship
between money and politics there's been
scandals over lobbying and cash for
questions calls for banned on second
jobs but no agreements on what to do but
today Sky News can reveal for the first
time just how much extra money is still
flowing into Westminster who it goes to
and where it comes from in a major
project with tortoise media we compiled
a comprehensive database that shows how
much MPS really earn the value of the
gifts they're given and the full scale
of donations to individuals and also
political parties the Westminster
accounts draws together information from
several public sources and for the first
time makes it all available to the
public in one place so over the course
of this week we're going to have special
reports built on what the database now
reveals including just how much MPS take
home and it also shows that since the
last election that was in 2019 they've
earned 17 point 0.1 million pounds on
top of their regular salaries with
around two-thirds of that money going to
just 20 MPS now all of this work it
should be said is legal most of the
biggest earners are conservatives led by
two former Prime Ministers our Deputy
political editor Sam coats has this
exclusive report
who funds our politics and our
politicians it's a question that's hung
over Westminster for Generations should
intend these be banned from having
second jobs duck houses and moats you
couldn't make it up
and one does never been easy to answer
enough is enough we know the rules were
broken money and Scandal have long been
part of the fabric of our politics I
wouldn't hesitate to do it again
tomorrow but once they're over the
answer is always the same we are going
to hold MPS to account we need a totally
transparent system promise after promise
of transparency but little real progress
until now as we open westminster's
accounts and make them accessible to
everyone
foreign
who is giving what to MPS which
politicians earn the most how does
business try and get its way we took
data from Parliament records the
register of members Financial interests
and the Electoral commission to present
a fuller picture than ever before of
outside earnings or second jobs gifts
and donations to MPS as well as
donations to political parties for
decades all of this information was
clouded in a peak language and filed
away in Dusty tomes in shelves in
Westminster
Sky News and our partners tortoise media
have been working to change that so we
can all follow the flow of money through
our political system now turning
thousands of confusing written entries
into a database available at the touch
of a button allowing us to tell stories
like we never could before like this
over 17 million pounds that the total
amount of outside earnings the MPS have
declared in the course of this
Parliament just three years and it's on
top of their annual 84 000 pound salary
and this might be one reason why reform
is so hard when a Tory government's in
number 10 of the 17 million 15 million
pounds in earnings made by MPS goes to
conservatives now for the first time we
can sort MPS in order of what they make
from second jobs and other outside
earnings this here is the leaderboard
these people the top 20 made close to
two-thirds of all the outside earnings
in this Parliament again it's dominated
by conservatives 17 of the top 20 are
Tory MPS the person at the top of this
list is familiar to everyone it's former
prime minister Theresa May declaring
over two and a half million pounds life
Post Number 10 appears to have been
treating her well either my right
honorable friend had not read the rules
or didn't understand what they meant and
others around him or they didn't think
the rules applied to number 10 which was
it
this is what the former prime minister
wants you to see out of office but still
upholding standards and holding her
successes to account but away from the
commons are packed and lucrative
schedule
since leaving number 10 Mrs May has
earned 10 times her MP's salary giving
dozens of speeches to a host of
different audiences from American Banks
to the Danish legal profession a hundred
and thirteen thousand pounds for a
speech to a scientific conference 136
000 pounds for an address to the World
Knowledge Forum a former prime minister
in huge demand even in countries which
she took on as prime minister
it was the murder of activist and
journalist Jamal khashoggi in 2018 that
made Theresa May a firm critic of Saudi
Arabia I can update the house that no
minister or official is attending the
investment conference in Saudi Arabia as
well as demanding answers she blocked
her ministers from visiting the country
for a conference
spank time
four years on and a very different
approach it seems the rich diversity of
cultures religions and beliefs the
former pm on stage herself in the
capital of Saudi Arabia at a travel
conference telling the audience it was a
pleasure to be in Riyadh and being paid
a hundred and seven thousand Pounds
for almost two months Sky News has been
trying to get Theresa May to talk about
her outside earnings her office
acknowledges receipt of our questions
but the promised reply never comes this
is Theresa May's constituency office
we're just gonna knock on the door
we went on a Friday when MPS are
typically in their constituencies to get
answers that way but no luck it is a
shame that Theresa May isn't here
because she says that the money that she
earns goes into this a company called
the office of Theresa May limited here
are the accounts and that she pays
herself a salary of 85 000 pounds a year
from this company and the rest of the
cash goes to support her charitable work
and to pay for other activities as a
former prime minister but looking at
these accounts is just not quite clear
how that works the cash seems to come
into this company but it's not clear
where it goes from there and now we
can't ask Theresa May what's going on we
know Theresa May is involved in
charitable work but under this system we
just can't see how much or where the
money goes
her maidenhead constituent willing to
make up their mind without the answers
we go that's a lot of money
so I I think if she's more focused on
doing that than being a teacher MP
certainly will affect it MP should be
doing that doing their job not getting
involved in all these other things you
know are you surprised people pay a lot
of money to hear her speak
yeah that's what I'm surprised about
Theresa May she doesn't know what's
happening in maidenhead
some are more supportive it all depends
what she's talking about if somebody
wants to pay money to her who's to sing
why not it's not just the former prime
minister who's been declaring she's
earning big sums on top of her day job
Sir Jeffrey Cox is a second MP that has
declared they topped two million pounds
already earned in this Parliament he's
coming from legal work he says his
experience as a practicing Barrister is
invaluable to politics and he spends no
more time than a cabinet minister would
on their job flying up this leaderboard
another former prime minister Boris
Johnson since his resignation he's
become an earnings Juggernaut he walked
out of number 10 in September and has
already earned over a million pounds
he's hit that total with his earnings
from just four speeches
for a single speech in New York he was
paid at a rate of 32 and a half thousand
pounds per hour that's more than the
starting salary for a British nurse over
a whole year earned in just 60 Minutes
work Liz truss still hundreds of places
below both her predecessors her earnings
total under a thousand pounds royalties
for a decade old book also in the top
five the former head of Margaret
Thatcher's policy unit and former
cabinet minister John Redwood making big
money with a big job title as well as
being MP for wokingham he's the chief
Global strategist for the investment
firm Charles Stanley declaring earnings
of nearly 700
000 pounds from the company since the
last election here praising the growth
of video conferencing because it means
he can do more for the firm someone who
is obviously part-time
I think I'm far more efficient as a
result of these changes because I can
for example break off today and and
share a conference with you for for an
hour at four o'clock in the afternoon
uh whereas I wouldn't necessarily be
able to do that if I had to travel an
hour or two hours to get to a given
venue or an office so I can actually do
more Shadow foreign secretary David
Lammy has been a busy man he lists more
sources of outside income than any other
MP receiving money from over three dozen
separate companies speaking to voters
yes but declaring significant earnings
at the same time David Lammy sits at
kierstama's top table Shadow foreign
secretary for over a year one of the
biggest jobs in the shadow cabinet at a
time of international crisis Mr Lammy
has juggled that role with a range of
outside work a radio show speeches and
training courses for corporations
a lengthy section on his personal
website promotes his skills as a paid
public speaker on a broad sweep of
different topics we're certainly living
in uncertain times from crisis
management if America Retreats from the
world to U.S politics
and companies have clearly been taking
notice David Lammy has listed at least
30 speaking and training engagements
since December 2019 worth around a
hundred thousand pounds as well as more
than 87 000 pounds for a radio program
on LBC
all of this hard to square with the
labor leaders firm line against second
jobs ban all second jobs for MPS
with very limited exceptions neither
kiss dharma's team nor David lamis were
able or willing to set out if his
outside work would qualify for an
exemption from the ban I'm on a
political show putting political views
and putting the views of my constituents
Mr Lemmy's office acknowledged receipt
of our questions but chose not to
respond Mr Lammy has however made an
impassioned defense of his second jobs
on his radio show why am I here why am I
pleased to be here because one I'm the
only black presenter on LBC
it's important for my constituents I
love the fact that they approach me and
they can hear me putting views that they
agree with out there into the public
some of his Tottenham constituents like
having a visible local MP I think he's
focused enough on the job of being a
politician yeah and I think you think
he's focusing up on Tottenham even
though he's
making all this money outside yeah
because he's accessible which is which I
think is you know it can't be can't be
said of lots of others for some
constituents it's not the radio show
that's the problem
Lloyds of London JP Morgan Chase Canary
Wharf group GSK some of those are quite
shocking uh to me ask why he did them I
guess and
you know does he agree with the
practices or the values of these
companies I think if that was brought up
for me I'd make me squirm a bit probably
and rightly so all allowed under the
rules which permit MPS to do almost any
second job apart from lobbying MPS
themselves often point out it's no
different from being a cabinet minister
but this is an admission that for some
being an MP is not necessarily a
full-time occupation
coming up with a single easily
comparable figure for outside earnings
unlikely to go down well with MPS who
could have done it themselves there's no
incentive for MPS really to make it easy
to do the sort of comparison that you've
done in this exercise it's much easier
for them to say we've been transparent
the data is out there people can go and
look for it if they want to but in fact
that data isn't very easy to use and
it's not real transparency
MP's earnings information is just one
benefit of the new public tools Sky News
has commissioned from tortoise media
more than half a million different
pieces of data about your MP and all MPS
now able to be explored by anyone
tomorrow we look at donations more
findings more League tables only
possible because of the Westminster
accounts project and these prompt the
question
does what MPS tell us give us the whole
picture
we'll be hearing from Sam later in the
program we'll also have more stories
from the Westminster accounts in the
coming days but now it's time for our
first interview of the new year and it's
the big one we can talk now to the man
hoping to become the UK's next prime
minister Labor's kirst armor and find
out what he would do if he got the keys
to number 10. thanks very much for being
on the program good morning very good to
be your first interview of the Year
morning yeah it's good to have you uh as
well
um I'm Keen to get to your vision yeah
to what you would do if you were the
next prime minister but first I just
want your reaction to the Westminster
accounts project whatever your views on
you know political donations on outside
earnings surely more transparency has
got to be a good thing transparency is a
good thing I think that you've obviously
pulled together a lot of information
there made it publicly available I think
it was all in the public domain because
it's all been declared according to
we've got strong rules as you know I
think we've got some of the strongest
rules in terms of what we have to
declare
um but you know the more transparency
the better so everybody can see exactly
what has been declared and ask whatever
questions they want about it yeah and I
think it's the accessibility when you
can pull up whoever you want you know
your own entry I guess you think it's
important for your own top team to be
transparent as well yes I mean I think
uh it's fair to say that uh everybody is
declaring in accordance with the rules
that being in place for some time what
you've done is bring that all together
in one place but it's all been declared
according to the rules absolutely right
um I think the thing that's interesting
about the project for me anyway is that
you can have a comparison as well so you
know what's usual in terms of earnings
and what is perhaps not and it is also
fair to say that the if you're looking
at the higher standards the vast
majority are conservative and peace
nearly all nearly uh just want to have a
look uh on November the 16th 2021 you
made a speech on how to improve
parliamentary standards and you said
these are the changes that labor is
calling for first a ban on all second
jobs for MPS with very limited
exceptions and then 13 days after that
speech David lamu becomes foreign
secretary you can have a look at his
entry on our database and he's earned
106 000 pounds since the 16th of
November 2021 which is when you made the
speech so how is that compatible with
your ban on second job well Sophie what
I was proposing was
um assistant for all MPS that we should
ban second jobs there's a discussion
about what exemptions there should be I
think David for example does a lot of
media work and I think media work and
writing books is all part of the
political process but there's a
discussion to be had what I was urging
was for the whole House of Commons to
agree new rules because I do think that
we should get rid of second jobs with
some exceptions some people have jobs
where they need to top up their skills
um and I do think if you write a
political book or uh you know
yeah exactly that may be grounds for an
exemption but what I wanted what I still
want is for the whole House of Commons
to agree new rules which are stricter
than the rules that we've got and assume
we can do that the better so you
mentioned some exemptions so in your
view then making 90 000 pounds from a
weekly radio show as David Lamey has
would be an exemption or how about tens
of thousands from speeches to Bankers
Consultants Tech firms as he has to I
think parliament's got to come together
and decide what the exemptions should be
but I for my part I think the rule
should be stricter I think but you can't
say which jobs should be banned and
which should broadly speaking I think
that
um there's a million miles of difference
between someone who's you know advising
a company on strategy for example and
someone who's writing a political book
but look I'm open to a discussion on
this I think the rule should be stricter
I would like the House of Commons to
come together again and have another go
at changing the rules obviously
um when we said those things that was in
the middle of um some terrible rule
breaking that was going on in the House
of Commons last year last year was a
busy year but look do I think the rule
should be stricter yes I do do I think
it's very good that it's transparent yes
I do do I encourage the house to come
together because in the end it's not a
party political matter it's got to be
the whole of the House of Commons do I
want the House of Commons to come
together to have another look at it yes
and then we can have a discussion about
what the exemption should be the
narrower the better in my view but
obviously we've got to reach an
agreement go forward from there okay
thank you very much um
you want to be the next prime minister
right now for many of our viewers the
number one priority is the health status
yes what is your plan well I think
firstly we got to acknowledge that the
health services not just on its knees
it's on its face I think as we sit here
today there are 7.2 million people on
the waiting list speak to anyone who
works in the NHS and they'll tell you
just how stressed it is my wife works in
the NHS so I know this firsthand so the
NHS is on its face there are immediate
things that we have to do to get through
this winter
um but I think that bigger than that
we've got to have change and reform
we've got to make sure the NHS is
sustainable not just through this winter
but over the next 10 years and that's
why I've asked West streeting to do our
work on change and reform and I want a
10-year plan for Change and reform of
the NHS and that's what we would usher
in as a labor government not just the
sort of what I've called the sticking
plaster politics of getting through the
winter crisis but actually fixing the
underlying problems and changing the NHS
so for example I think we need much more
preventative work we need to intervene
much more quickly and I want to see
Health accessible in our community so
there's big change
um and I think it's for the labor party
to do that we set up the NHS and we will
ensure the future of the NHS but just at
the moment we've got a crisis and it's
the worst crisis we've ever had and
that's because we've had 13 years of
neglect and worse you think then the
pressure currently oh if you look I mean
of course covered put extra pressure on
the NHS nobody would deny that certainly
not me with my wife working in one of
the big London hospitals I know what
stress that put us under but the waiting
lists were you know 4.6 million before
we went into covid the
difficulties we've had with Workforce
has been there for a very very long time
they've never been fixed by this
government so one of the one of the
first steps we would do and we've
already set out is to get rid of the
non-dom status which allows very wealthy
people not to pay their tax in this
country we'll get rid of that and use
the money from that to double the number
of medical students coming into the NHS
so that's the first practical step but
we've got to go much further than that
change in reform is what is needed we're
going to consult on this in the course
of the coming months and then there'll
be a 10-year plan for the NHS under the
next Labor government you are doing the
thing that some people are very
frightened of doing which is talking
about private sector involvement as well
um in your speech this week you talked
about the public and private sectors
working in Partnership there's been a
move where you want to see more use of
beds in the private sector just explain
the thinking there well um the immediate
problem is obviously the waiting lists
and um one of the issues that we've
looked at is whether or not we're using
the private sector effectively a number
of people do go as an HS patients to the
private sector our research shows that
that's been underused and we could do
more of it and that would clear you know
230 000 people off the waiting units in
the private sector in the NHS under
labor yes but I mean let me be clear
we're not talking about privatizing the
NHS we're used we're talking about using
the private sector effectively
um and free at the point of use is an
absolutely governing Principle as we go
into this review but we do need change
and reform I want to look for example at
Primary Care would it be possible to use
local pharmacies more to do work on
prescriptions Etc is there a route for
self-referral what do we do about
um you know the Partnerships of GPS
which I don't think are necessarily as
efficient as they should be we're asking
all the questions that are a bold
incoming government should ask about
change and reform now we want to consult
because obviously
with the doctors unions that it sounds
like this could could prevent you're
willing to have that battle yeah we've
got to have battles I mean I ran a
Public Service the crown prosecution
service for five years in part as part
of the criminal justice system and I've
reformed that and my experience of
Reform is there will always be people
who say I wouldn't do that I'd keep it
as it is don't touch anything I totally
uh you know disregard that I think we've
got if there's change to be made we've
got to get on and make it so this isn't
a battle with a particular sector but it
is a statement of intent we need to
change we need to reform we need to make
sure the NHS can survive for decades to
come and that will mean change in reform
and we're not going to back down the
first time somebody says well I wouldn't
do that I wouldn't change this I just
want to have a look at one of your 10
Pleasures during your leadership
campaign to become uh the lead the labor
party and you said this in it you said
Public Services should be in public
hands
here we go public services should be in
public hands not making profits for
shareholders and this is to keep it end
Outsourcing in our NHS so why have you
changed your mind well we're not talking
about privatizing the energy or any
public well the NHS has always used
um elements from the private sector GPS
for an example is an example your pledge
he said end Outsourcing and NHS you've
changed your mind yeah well look the
Outsourcing of some issues and functions
I don't think has been very effective
but if you take the NHS the NHS is
always used uh GPS in private practice
that's always been part of it for many
many years the NHS has referred NHS
um you know patients to the private
sector to have operations hip operations
knee operations Etc I think we could be
more effective at that but I'm not
talking about privatizing the NHS the
same is true in criminal justice I do
think it should be run as a public
service but it doesn't mean there aren't
um there isn't a private sector in there
um self-employed barristers for example
from the private sector provide a
service in criminal justice in relation
to prosecutions what I want to ensure
that is that our Public Service which
frankly are on their knees I mean you
know ask your I I mean you know ask
yourself the question is any public
service now better than it was 13 years
ago when this government came in and I
don't think anybody with a straight face
could answer that question and say yes
they're better than they were no nor
could anyone frankly answer the question
do you feel personally better off over
the last 13 years or is our economy
better off almost all those questions
Peg only one answer which is no you um I
was quite interested earlier in the
interview when we talk about the NHS and
you were saying about how your wife
tells you stories about what's going on
what kind of thing does she say well you
know probably what everybody working in
the NHS so I mean my sister used to work
in the NHS my mum worked at NHS so I
know a lot about it and obviously a lot
of people we know work in the NHS but
it's completely under strain one of the
big big issues is Workforce and that's
why it's very important that we made
that commitment end on Dom status use
that money to train up the Next
Generation as well because people say
pay is a big pack yes we've got the
strikes of course as well and the leader
of the Royal College of nurses suggested
this last week that her members would
accept a 10 pay rise
would you would you agree to that well
look let me tell you the approach we
would take because I think many people
we know you'd get around a table and
negotiate but what kind of pay rides let
me just walk through and I'll obviously
answer your question don't worry about
that but just walk it through the nurses
have never ever had a national strike
before ever
they don't want to be on strike and it's
a badge of shame that for the government
that we're even in this situation all
they're asking for is the government to
get in the room and negotiate with them
and they said that before they're asking
for more money aren't they before the
strike started and that week before the
strike started they said if the
government comes into the room to talk
to us we won't go on strike and the
government has refused to do so
um if if we were in government we would
go in the room and discuss we would have
taken up that offer so the hypothetical
you're putting to me what would you do
if you were in government yes we would
roll our bus leaves we would go in and
we would talk to them we'd resolve this
issue and just add two other bits to
this firstly the when the nether was a
national strike under the last Labor
government 13 years ago
today is key isn't it would you would
you agree to a 10 pay rise for nurses
it's going to have to be compromised on
both sides I'm not going to sit here
answering hypothetical about the
situation you're asking me what would I
do in government if I was in government
I'd go into the room and negotiate but
equally so that's what they're doing
next week because if I was thinking if I
was in government
I wouldn't come on your show and say in
advance of that what percentage
um you know might be a compromise what
we would discuss any more than the trade
Unions would so I wouldn't expect the
government to come on your show and say
this is the percentage I would expect
the government to come on your show and
say yes we'll get in the room with the
nurses and we'll bring this strike to an
end okay and now you made a big speech
this week setting out your vision for
the country what's the most important
message from it do you think that
viewers should take away oh that we need
hope and change after 13 years of
failure we need hope and change we need
a decade of national renewal and that is
what we will bring about growing the
economy restoring our public services
and making sure that people have much
more of a certain influence over the
decisions that affect them now in the
speech you appropriated the language of
brexit you said that you were the man to
Take Back Control so you said this you
said as I went around the country
campaigning for remain I couldn't
disagree with the basic case so many
leave voters made him me so is that why
you led the campaign for a second
referendum you said that you'd vote
remain in a second referendum and you
describe the leave vote as catastrophic
for the UK you said all that because you
just you agreed was leaving but Sophie
what I said in my speech is something
I've said actually many many times I've
always accept I voted remain I'm not
going to you know and I campaign and
then campaign for a second I I voted for
Maine I I campaigned for remain
um second referendum we lost the um
referendum but deeper than that
um beyond the technical question should
we be in the EU or not I felt that bound
up in that referendum was a big question
about change people desperately wanted
change that's why I think Take Back
Control was such a powerful slogan in a
way it was a Heineken phrase it got
inside people and if you can't make your
household budget balance you don't feel
you've got control if you don't feel
that you can send your child to a school
that is excellent in your area because
there isn't the schools excellent you
don't have control if you feel that
anti-social Behavior means you can't go
out in your neighborhood after dark you
don't have control that powerful case
for change over and Beyond the question
of EU membership was always that I've
always actually accepted that I think
most people who voted remain would
accept that as well yeah but I guess a
lot of people United Kingdom a lot of
lead voters will say you know they they
votedly because they want to leave the
EU I think it was more in that vote than
yesterday if you're honest do you think
you're shifting messages because the
electorate that mattered to you at then
was a pro remain party membership would
be voting for the next labor leader the
lecture that matters to you now when
you're promising to Take Back Control
are those swing voters many of them who
voted for brexit are you changing your
message to suit your own purpose no
Sophie I've long reflected on that 2016
referendum as I've reflected on the
Scottish referendum in 2014 where you
know a large number of people voted yes
of course you know the technical
question on the ballot paper was
membership of the EU or you know
Independence in Scotland but sitting
behind that I think there was a very
powerful emotional case for change which
I don't think most remainers
um would argue with I certainly didn't
I've always argued that the other side
of Brett brexit is delivering the change
that's needed in this country well let's
talk about that's what I was setting out
my speech uh just earlier this week
let's talk about some of the changes
that people wanted immigration a big
part of the Take Back Control message
for many people and obviously a big
political issue now was small boats and
also record levels of immigration so 1.1
million people arrived in the UK in the
last year is that too low or too high
well look so if you're not going to get
into a numbers game we need Fair rules
um firmly applied and we need to
distinguish between the different
reasons that people come to this country
some people come to join their families
I think broadly speaking most people
accept that that's perfectly all right a
number come to as students and I want
the best students from across the world
to come here some arrive as refugees
including from places like like
Afghanistan and Ukraine and obviously we
welcome them as we always have done and
some come to work now what I've said in
a speech I did earlier in fact at the
tail end of last year is that when it
comes to those coming to work of course
we recognize and welcome the
contribution that everybody who comes to
this country makes but what I've said to
the CBI is we need to wean ourselves off
this sense that rather than skill up and
train people in this country we can
simply bring people in from other
countries I don't think that's right I
think that we can do far better on the
skills in this country so I think
there's room for fair rules for firmly
applied and for a national debate about
what we want from immigration one of the
reasons I'm Keen to get your view on
this is because it feels to be that you
have shifter I guess on immigration
again in the last few years so in the
leadership campaign I can see on one
side of the screen one of your pledges
was to defend free movement as we leave
the EU of elidship pledge in 2020 and
then compare that to a melon Sunday
interview freedom of movement is a red
line for me it won't come back well
let's just look at those these are
diametrically opposable of course
they're not look defend free movement as
we leave the EU right we've left no so
now we've got to face the future we're
in we're out of the EU free movement has
gone so the question then comes well
what do you want now do you want to go
back or do you want to have a different
system with Fair rules except this is as
we leave the EU but this is this is
acknowledging that we're leaving the EU
and saying that you'll be defending free
movement as we leave but we've left
we've left and therefore free moment
free movement was part of the package
for being a member of the EU inevitably
um we've left free movement has come to
an end now for a different question
arises which is what immigration system
do you want now and I think we should
have a fair system with Fair rules that
are firmly applied and that's what we
would devise so it's nothing to do with
the fact that in the leadership campaign
you were pitching to pro-remain labor
members and now you're again looking at
those swing voters many of them who
voted brexit if you don't like my
principles I have others there's nothing
to do with that I think so here I mean
it's obvious what that pledge was as we
leave the EU we've left the EU we've got
to face the future as it is but I see
this the other thing that I said when we
did lots and lots of speeches and
hostings uh materials in that leadership
campaign my overwhelming pitch the labor
party was we have to win the next
election otherwise none of the things
we're talking about are kind of come to
pass and we've lost elections
consistently since 20 10 I'm determined
that that won't happen again and that's
why I set myself when I became leader of
this party just under three years ago
three tasks the first was to change the
labor party when you lose as badly as we
did in 2019 you don't look at the
electorate and say what were you doing
you look at your party and say we're
going to change and we've been really
clear about the change that we've
brought about within the party whether
that's anti-Semitism whether that's NATO
whether that's our relationship with
business the second thing is we have to
expose the government has not fit to
govern well you can see what 13 years of
failure has done the next stage is to
lay out the alternative we began to do
that last year and 2023 is this chance
for us to set out would a bold reforming
labor government will do let's just have
a look at a picture of you this week
giving your speech if I'm a you looked
pretty relaxed and confident when you
gave the speech you know you had no
jacket you had your sleeves rolled up
you know is that the look of a man who
thinks he's going to be the next prime
minister I hope so yes um what I was
doing there was setting out
the case for 2023 for Hope for Change
and the sort of bold change double we
need a decade of national renewal and I
think
um the next election is going to be
about change and you know if anybody
asks themselves am I better off than I
was in 2010 when this government first
came in I think the answer will be no
are our Public Services any better now
than they were then the answer will be
no
the answer will be no so we desperately
need change what I want to do is to set
out that case for change okay not not
just what the change will be but also
how we're going to bring it about
looking ahead to 2023 you can have time
to read the Prince Harry book I don't
know I haven't uh set aside time yet are
you sympathetic with him or well look my
governing principle is that politicians
shouldn't Wade in to private matters of
the royal family I know it's not private
at the minute right well but some
politicians like to wait and Give
opinions left right and Center I
actually don't and I think it's better
not to weigh it in maybe this one then
it's 2023 the year that Arsenal going to
win the Premier League I really hope so
we're we're so tight at the top
um we've got to keep going it's a
fantastic scored really good team of
players there we're in a very very good
position okay uh thank you very much
indeed kirst armor leader of the labor
party uh well that was uh the view from
the opposition time now to get the view
from the government whether it's delays
getting ambulances or the huge backlogs
for care for many people the NHS is the
number one political issue right now and
tomorrow the government's going to be
meeting union leaders in a bid to try
and avert further strike action in a
Health Service that is already on the
brink or still doing shifts as a cancer
nurse at Health Minister Maria Caulfield
knows the NHS better than most she joins
us now thank you very much for being
with us today I'm very keen to get on to
the NHS but first if I may I just want
to get your reaction to the Westminster
accounts project launched by sky today a
transparency tool effectively for the
money that is coming into politics do
you welcome more transparency well I was
an MP when the expense is Scandal uh
broke a number of years ago and of
course we all welcome the transparency
um it is very clear we all have to
declare any outside interests any
outside earnings so people can go onto
the parliament website and look for
themselves as well but I think you know
what was important during the expensive
Scandal was to try and end uh
professional politicians just being the
only route into being an MP and so you
are seeing people coming into
Westminster with outside interest I'm a
nurse I still work as a nurse I declare
those earnings on my website and then
you know cross party we have doctors who
work in the labor party on our side and
conservative party and I think it's
important that people are able to keep
their interests in in that sort of field
going it certainly helps me in terms of
my work as a local constituency MP but
also as a health minister to really see
what's happening on the ground let's
bring up your own entry shall we because
you mentioned it yourself
um you can see your entry on the
database here and we can look in a bit
more detail at some of your own
donations and earnings
um the first thing if we have a look
that stands out as you mentioned the 8
890 pounds of earnings from the Royal
Marston hospital so that's your work as
a nurse that you continue to do yeah and
I guess some would argue that's you know
good example of MPS having outside and
also MPS like myself you know politics
is a Fickle game If You're Not Elected
at the next election then I would go
back to working as a nurse and you have
to keep your registration so sometimes
there's some a practical element to it
and actually my constituents really were
pleased to see me go back during covid
back onto the wards and help out where I
could and I guess it gives you a
perspective on some of the issues as
well absolutely
um you can also see that at the bottom 3
250 pounds of gifts from the betting and
gaming Council what was that
relationship so that was an event I went
to I went to to Wimbledon and a
constituent invited me who happens to
work for the betting and and gaming
Council so and that's that's what I mean
transparency is there my constituents
can look on the website parliamentary
website and ask me well what what is
that about you can see donations there
that were for the last general election
now they come to the party but if
they're allocated to you you have to
declare them as well again yeah so I so
you will be getting donations going up
to election time I just want to have a
look at the bottom one a bit more
because we can also have a look at the
total recipients for the betting and
gaming Council another feature on the
website you're one of around 30 MPS who
receive gifts from them now on their
website they say they represent betting
shops casinos online and bingo they work
to in their words Drive High ethical
standards create a culture of safer
betting and gaming and build public and
institutional trust in our world-class
industry now as you say all these gifts
have been declared in the proper way
they're within the rules
but in your views is it appropriate well
my my example is one from a constituent
who works for them so you have to
declare that there's a a vested interest
there and that is to to make it open and
transparent I haven't actually been
involved in any
um work with the betting and gaming
Council but that's the level of
transparency that have is there any
connection at all and as a minister you
also have to declare any interests too
and then overall on earnings we found
that MPS have earned 17.1 million pounds
today on top of their salaries since the
last election and I have to say that is
overwhelmingly conservative MPS 15.4
million pounds of that money from
conservative MPS I mean is that okay in
your opinion well I think what I was
watching the report earlier two of those
are from former primary this is a prime
former Prime Ministers do get paid for
political speeches so it's part of their
political work but I think the the best
judges of all of this will be
constituents and you know if
constituents don't feel uh that an MP is
giving 100 to their constituency
um you know they've got The Ballot Box
to make that ultimate decision and I
think you know someone like Theresa May
is you know fantastically well known for
working so hard in our constituency even
when she was prime minister she was
marshaling uh fun runs and sporting
events
um and I think the the current prime
minister is very very clear he expects
every MP to give 100 to their
constituency and it is possible to work
full-time as an MP and to do to do other
things
um you know I do night shifts and
weekends so that I don't impact on my
constituency work
um but I think it is you know it is
important that MPS do have uh come from
The Real World and that sometimes will
mean that they do have jobs outside of
parliament I guess
um there's kind of two sort of concerns
people may have the first one about
whether or not MPS are refocused on
their number one job which is big and MP
and I think you kind of touched on it
there I guess a second one is that these
companies are indirectly buying
influence in Parliament
well what I would say I mean sometimes I
do take uh take the The View that
sometimes it's always portrayed the MPS
on the make you know you know how how
long hours MPS work you know it's a
seven day a week job we work long into
the night many times a week not just in
Parliament but in our own constituencies
this week I've worked you know seven
days a week I'll be working seven days a
week this week as well so it is a very
very um long unsocial job and I just
sometimes think it's it's important that
we also reflect the good work that MPS
do as well as some of the concerns
absolutely that's why the transparency
rules were brought in so that any
donation any income is there for
everyone to see and then constituents
can make their own minds up about
whether their constituency MP is working
hard for them okay
um well let's have a look now shall we
at the NHS um with your kind of Health
Minister hatout we've touched on it a
bit with your work at the Royal Marsden
it feels to me like a lot of people
might be genuinely quite frightened
right now about the state of the house
service I mean we can just take a look
at this graph um this shows the number
of ambulances waiting longer than an
hour to hand over to patients so we know
what that means that's ambulances backed
up but outside hospitals with people
inside uh that can't get a bed it's it's
yeah it's concerning the red line at the
top is this current year and you can see
it's far higher than at any point during
the pandemic I mean this isn't a Health
Service that's in crisis well winter is
always a difficult time you know my 25
years of nursing I can see the
comparison to other Winters here it
feels an exceptional winter it is an
exceptional winter and I was just about
to say that you know I've worked in uh
normal Winters when we've had ambulances
queuing and declared critical incidents
at the end e that I worked at but this
is a different Year we're seeing a twin
demic of both covid and flu so we're
seeing
um even compared to in the last decade
the most fluid mission that we've seen
there's nearly over five thousand people
in hospital at the moment with flu over
6 000 in hospital with covid and many of
those are over 65 with lots of
comorbidities which means they're much
more unwell in hospital and that shows
you the scale of the numbers that we
wouldn't normally see even in the winter
when we have normal winter pressures and
staff are also facing those pressures we
have around 60 000 staff members in the
NHS off sick in any one day at the
moment because they too get respiratory
on the stairs covered flu and so that's
also having an impact on services so
this is a very very uh difficult winter
even compared to most usual ones I mean
our next guest who will hear from in a
moment Dr Adrian Boyle president of the
Royal College of emergency medicine he
believes there are around 300 to 500
unnecessary deaths every week because of
delays in emergency care do you accept
people are dying because of delays well
we know that this is a difficult winter
we know there are excess deaths for a
number of reasons you know the chief
medical officers
I don't recognize the figure that you've
you've quoted there but what I can say
is that we are working really really
hard to get people into hospital we know
that around 13 000 people are in
hospital in any one day that shouldn't
be
um that is a shifting group of people
that's not the same 13 000 every single
day if you look at December we've got 8
000 of those patients out of hospital
with care packages either to home or to
care homes or to other settings and yet
the next day another group of patients
are admitted really unwell with covid
with flu with respiratory illnesses and
they are often complex patients who
again will take time to discharge that's
why the Prime Minister held the Forum
yesterday with a range of health
professionals to see what more we can do
we've given 500 million this winter to
get Social care packages in place to get
people out of hospital because that's
the number one reason why ambulances are
stuck at the doors of a E's because they
can't unload their patients because a
E's can't discharge their patients to
the wards so that's why we're focusing
on social care you know when when I
interview people who work in the Health
Service I think that's a bit of a
frustration frankly at the government
trying to say that this is just because
of covid it's just because of an
exceptional flu year and they say it's
actually because of under investment in
the health service that goes back for
years and I just want to have a look at
this this is a funding chart and it
shows the annual changes in health
spending and you can really see that
from when the conservatives came into
power in 2010 there has been a four a
queer squeeze in funding for the Health
Service I mean you're a nurse you
obviously care deeply about the NHS do
you understand why people might be you
know angry I guess or you've missed off
for a couple of years so to be fair this
is it's not been missed off this is
where it ends right well no so we've
increased by 11 the funding in the last
couple of do you accept do you accept
that once 2010 between 2010 and 2020
there was a squeeze in funding for the
Health Service that people are now
saying in the health services is
directly related to shortage of beds a
shortage of doctors what are they saying
is that and the Institute of fiscal
Studies have highlighted that and
they're not exactly Friends of the
government that there's record levels of
investment there is an 11 increase in
funding which is missing off your chart
that has meant that we're opening up 7
000 new beds um in the NHS it does mean
we're recruiting over 10 000 more nurses
which are in place now so you're having
to make up now for under investment
under previously we are investing in
record levels of funding not just for
the NHS but also for social care and
these issues that you see around
ambulances queuing up uh beds not being
available they're in all four devolved
Nations whether it's labor who are
running the NHS in Wales are facing
exactly the same pressures and sometimes
their performance in certain indicators
are worse than in England the UK
government just runs the Health Service
in England the SNP in Scotland are
facing exactly the same pressures
um and it's not just within the UK If
you look at other countries Ireland
Italy Spain
let's look at some other countries I
think we can also show so here we go
this is hospital beds per 100 000 people
the red line in the middle is the
average and then you have to go all the
way down only Sweden is lower than the
UK so if you're looking at International
comparison or hospital beds we're doing
pretty poorly so yeah again you're
looking at 2020 data in the last two the
latest we're opening up 7 000 new beds
uh within the NHS we're also opened we
have opened already over 90 surgical
hubs which is tackling our surgical
backlog of seven million people we've
cleared almost completely 13 years but
we've cleared almost completely the two
people waiting for two years or more for
their surgical waiting list we're on
track to meet those waiting 18 months by
April and then we'll be focusing on
those waiting for a year so to to you
know we need to look at the most
up-to-date figures seven thousand extra
beds will make a huge difference to the
NHS okay let's talk about strikes uh
shall we because the Prime Minister has
invited union leaders to have what he
calls grown-up honest talks tomorrow
there are going to be at these
conversations with their representative
departments is a health secretary
prepared to budge when it comes to pay
so the health secretary has invited the
unions to meet with him this week as
part of this initiative and it is to
talk about both pay and conditions he's
already met with uh Hey because that's a
shift it feels like before we'll talk
about conditions now the government is
prepared to move on but we want to talk
about pay uh the settlement for this
year because the government is about to
submit evidence the independent pay
review body for the pay award for this
year and I think it's really important
to have those discussions with the
unions about what's realistic but also
what they're they're looking for as well
so that we can send the most robust
information and evidence to the
independent pay review buddy that's a
clear change isn't it because previously
you were saying that it was conditions
that were on the table and now it's pay
and conditions well I think the
difference is we are now looking at this
year's pay pay award and we want to make
fast progress on that and we want to be
able to submit evidence to the pay
review bodies that the the unions uh
will also be submitting their evidence
too so that when the award is is made
that there should be hopefully a
consensus around what's awarded so we're
not looking at going back at pay Awards
we're really focused on the pay awards
for this year okay and now just finally
I want to talk to you with your you know
women and inequalities hat on because
the Scottish government has passed new
legislation to introduce
self-identification system for people
who want to change gender do you welcome
that or do you have concerns well I know
the Secretary of State uh Cami badinal
who's responsible overall for this area
has has some concerns and has written to
the Scottish government I know that they
are looking at that at the moment we do
have some concerns obviously we want to
make sure that for those people who want
to transition we're improving the
process and speeding up well it's quite
a clunky process at the moment but we
want to protect women's rights as well
and we have some concerns and that's why
kemi has written to the Scottish
government and is reviewing that at the
moment I just want to know how far
you're willing to go if you do have
those concerns because immediately after
the vote the Scottish secretary asked
Jack said the UK government had concerns
as you there in particular over what he
describes as safety issues for women
children and then he went on to say we
will look closely at that and also the
ramifications of the 2010 equality act
and other uk-wide legislation in the
coming weeks up to and including a
section 35 order stopping the bill going
for Royal Ascent so are you genuinely
considering blocking this bill in
Westminster well that'll be a matter for
cabinet and as you say the Scottish
secretary and Kimmy badnock who's the
equalities secretary are looking at that
and having a discussions the
conservatives were the only party that
voted against that legislation we do
have concerns but that will be a matter
that will be discussed at cabinet before
the final decision is taken okay but on
the table then well you know both the
Scottish secretary and the equality
secretary have indicated that okay thank
you very much for being on the program
today Maria Caulfield there
you are watching safety Ridge on Sunday
busy show for us at this morning Lots on
the NHS and also of course on our
Westminster accounts a project looking
at money in the political system well
with that in mind we can talk now to
Adaptive political editor Sam uh coats
you can talk us through a reaction to
interviews and his uh reports at the top
of the show uh great to have you on the
program in the studio for once Sam as
well uh always um a pleasure so first
just just brings up what exactly have
you been doing
I mean to be honest Sophie this has been
quite an enormous project it's taken
about seven months more than 30 people
across two different uh organizations
all to try and just to bring a bit more
transparency a bit shine a bit more of a
light on the way that money Works in our
politics when it comes to earnings when
it comes to donations just to understand
a bit better what's going on and I'm
very struck that both of the guests that
you had this morning immediately none of
them looked desperately delighted that
we'd done this work because they said
that everything is already out there
it's all declared it's all transparent
already and our view I think is up to a
point Lord copper because although yes
MPS do declare that outside earnings and
their gifts and their donations on the
parliament website it's rather hard to
get to the bottom of actually what's
going on and to compare 1mp with another
so this morning Sky News in association
with our Media Partners tortoise media
have done as it were three things first
of all we have taken all of those public
bits of information and turned them into
a giant spreadsheet effectively we've
taken that register of members financial
interest which is on the parliament
website and turned it into one document
so we've effectively assigned an
earnings figure a donations figure for
each MP they're not desperately going to
like that but that's what we've done
this morning the second thing that we've
done is that we are putting that in the
public domain so it's not only for us
you at home can look at it you can go
onto the Sky News app the Sky News
website and there you will be able to
access the tool at the heart of the
Westminster account and the third thing
we've done is a few days worth we've
been looking at this information we've
done days worth of Journalism beginning
today yeah it's interesting isn't it
because um it has taken months if you
say you've got a cost on that of
information to look through and I know
that you you know your producer Tom
Larkin our partners uh tortoise have
spent a long time going through all of
this so we'll stand out then what would
have you found that's interesting so so
because you've put it in a spreadsheet
because all this information is now
sortable you effectively create a series
of leaderboards top tens top hundreds
and again MPS do not like this but every
day we're going to look effectively at a
different leaderboard for a different
aspect of how money Works in politics
and today we were looking at outside
earnings and you saw that chart that for
the first time ever you've been able to
do about the scale of outside earnings
in this Parliament went from the highest
Theresa May downwards and I the purpose
of that from where we said is not to say
that second jobs are good or bad there
are arguments on both sides not to say
that money and politics for example
talking about her husband work as a
nurse it is simply to say we want to
understand and we want to be able to
compare in order so that us constituents
viewers voters can get a better
understanding of what's going on and
what was interesting I think actually
this really came out in your interview
uh with uh the labor leader kirstarmer
is that
MPS are often more comfortable talking
about the big picture than when it gets
to specifics and the highest outside
earning labor MP is David halami who
sits at kirstama's right hand on that
top table and uh you put him a whole
load of specifics about the quite a lot
of quite considerable media work but
also speeches and training that he does
in the roles that he's had in the
shattered cabinet and I just thought it
was very Stark that I didn't hear from
Kia stama a definitive ruling whether he
thought that that work was right or
wrong even though he himself is labor
leader has made a huge amount of
political Capital essentially saying we
have to ban second jobs with a rider
with certain exemptions he couldn't say
whether he thought what David Lammy did
should or shouldn't be an exemption a
little bit uncomfortable there and it's
those specific questions that really
bring I think into sharp focus when you
look at the data in this way that's one
of the reasons that we've done the
Westminster account and there will be
more different elements of money in
politics takes in the days to come look
forward to seeing what else you got up
your sleeve Sam thanks very much for
coming into the studio and explaining
that to us
well it feels like we've gone through
the political arguments from both major
parties on westerns for accounts but
also the NHS this morning the other huge
issue that of course is impacting all of
ours and our families and we can now
hear from the very front line of the
Health Service emergency departments
where those in greatest danger are taken
seem to be on the brink huge wait for
care sick people on trolleys and
corridors ambulance waiting hours
critical incidents declared and the
Royal College of emergency medicine says
that hundreds yes hundreds of people
could be dying each week because of the
state of the service well its president
and a serving consultant in an emergency
department Dr Adrian Boyle was in
Downing Street yesterday meeting the
Prime Minister he joins us now it's a
real pleasure to have you on the program
so thank you for coming uh in
um we mentioned it there you went into
at number 10 and you spoke to the prime
ministers among others about the state
of the NHS thinking to the picture of
you standing on the gates of Downing
Street how was the meeting
um so we're really pleased that it's
been acknowledged at the highest level
and it's that we recognize there's a
crisis because there is a crisis in
emergency medicine we know and this
crisis is much worse you know every
winter we seem to go through this thing
there's another Annie crisis but it's
important to recognize that what's going
on at the moment is much worse and the
graphs that you were putting up
beforehand showed that yeah and the
visible markers are ambulances waiting
outside hospitals but that is only a
visible marker of the whole system of
being under stress and what we're seeing
is if you go into the emergency
department you'll see the people being
looked after in inappropriate areas with
long ways to be admitted and if you go
onto the wards they're full and
fundamentally the big problem we've got
is as you you showed that we don't have
enough beds our hospitals are too full
for us to do the jobs that we need them
to do it's interesting because you
mentioned there about how we talk about
winter crisis all the time that this is
different and I have to say you know
I've been doing this job for some years
I've spoken to a lot of people working
in the house service at this time and it
feels quite different now I mean
oh frankly you know you guys seem quite
frightened is that true yes I mean it's
important that people realize that if
they think they need to seek help they
do seek help and one of the anxieties
that we have about all the frost that's
going on at the moment is that people
who are um will sit at home when really
they should be seeking help that's
really important but at the same time
pretty much everyone I spoke to they
will say I've never seen it as bad as
this not even during the height of the
covert pandemic so in a very very
different way
um yes kovid was an extraordinary time
and but all sorts of things went over it
this feels worse because it's so there's
so many bits strands to it and it's so
difficult and the long Waits that we've
got are water so dangerous and what
we're so worried about and you I mean I
guess the biggest thing people worry
about is safety about lives right and
you believe that lives are being lost
because of delays it's not just belief
so there's some scientific evidence to
back us up with papers that have been
published in scientific journals
everybody who's looked at this has
always found that when you start getting
long waits in emergency departments you
see an increase in mortality
um so there's reasonable scientific data
to support this but not only that we've
also got separate analyzes where people
have looked at ons data and have
suggested that the increase that we've
seen in excess mortality through this
year and there will be lots of factors
at play it's not one single thing but
there'll be lots of factors it's
entirely plausible and it shows this so
we think that problems accessing urgent
and emergency care whether calling an
ambulance waiting a long time for that
being anxious about going to hospital or
the long waited an emergency departments
will be contributing to about a third or
a quarter of all this excess mortality
and you believe that's 300 500 people a
week yeah I mean it will vary but in a
way actually if the number doesn't
matter no you know it's actually about
what we do about it yeah and we know it
shows that there's a problem that needs
fixing okay and just before we get on to
what we should do because I am very keen
to get your view on that and you know
when you talk to ministers and the
government they talk about covert an
awful lot and they say look this is
because of covid because the pressures
we had during covert because of people
doing saying you know getting
appointments Etc
is that true or do these problems go
back longer oh the problem is go back
way longer you know if if you look at
performance indicators where we've been
having problems covert absolutely is yet
an additional thing and it's providing
it's taking a lot of disruption onto
hospitals but the problems that we're
causing this go back 2015 you know we
knew that this was a pun before but if
you go back before 2015 we did not have
problems with ambulance Handover delays
we did not have very often people
spending more than 12 hours in emergency
departments and is that under investment
so it's a variety of things
fundamentally the big problem is that we
just our hospitals are too full and you
put up that graph of not having enough
beds but also we're not using those beds
properly and actually in terms of what
we do with our beds we need to make sure
we're using those beds absolutely it's
efficiently and properly as possible
which I know part of that of course is
social care
um kirstama also talks on the program
today about using more capacity in the
private sector do you think that's a
good idea I think we we're in a state of
crisis at the moment and anything we can
do to reduce occupancy within hospitals
is the right thing to do it feels like
an expensive way to try and get
ourselves out of a pickle and I think
long term we've got to look at how we
actually stop this happening again and
that means actually getting to a
probably a more cost effective way to
try and do this by reforming the way we
do social care in this country and I'm
interested to know your thoughts on what
needs to happen in the short term but
also in the long term what do you think
needs to be done so it the big question
but fundamentally the thing we need to
do is reduce the occupancy in our
hospitals and that means having more
hospital beds and using those beds
better so fundamentally that's the big
problem that requires investment that
means also it's not just beds but it's
the workforce to look after them and we
do need to expand our Workforce
um you know and that's right across the
patch
um the government did announce more
money for the NHS in November Crawford
was talking about that an extra 3.3
billion pounds in each of the next two
years and I guess some would argue that
you know it's not just about money it's
not just about putting more and more
money into the NHS it's about reform too
otherwise the manufacturer is wasted do
you think that's true I think that's
fair I mean I I you know the NHS is an
enormous organization and there's always
things that we can do differently and
think innovatively about how we do this
and I think that's a fair challenge that
we need we need to do it but
repairing something that's broken cost a
lot of money
so more money is part of the issue that
we're formed to yes but you're dealing
with something that's fundamentally just
very very fragile and broken and that
takes a lot of work and you know
short-term big payments to try and buy
um uh aren't the way to do it we
actually need sustained predictable
funding so we can use that well rather
than just and that means things like
Capital funding and actually building
capacity not just on short-term salary
fixes and just looking forward I know
you don't want to talk directly about
Stripes which I understand there are
meetings going on uh tomorrow and our
strikes also having an impact on you
know the safe running of the NHS well we
need to have a sense of perspective you
know we've been in trouble for the last
the last year we had three strike days
days in December we're only having four
strike days yes they're disruptive yes
um they're they're difficult but you've
got a much bigger picture of terrible
working conditions
um that have been going on before okay
thank you very much indeed it's been
really interesting kind of having you on
the show so we appreciate it thank you
uh well that is it for this week's uh
Sophia Ridge on Sunday uh what a show
some really important issues discussed
uh today in a moment after the break
we're going to be running through
today's interviews and seeing what we
learned with our Deputy pleasure to Sam
coats we'll also have a special edition
of the sofa Ridge on Sunday podcast
should be available around at lunchtime
so check that out too
thanks for joining us at this Sunday
morning see you in a few moments
[Music]
hello and welcome to Sophia Ridge the
take where we take a moment and look
back at this morning's uh interviews
with some analysis from Sky's Deputy
political editor Sam coach who's here in
person today just in case you thought he
was just a mirage on the screen in most
uh weeks heater in person because of
course he's also launching this special
program uh to start 2023 the Sky News
investigation to skies and taught us we
should say into the money that MPS get
from donations gifts and outside
earnings it's been 10 months in the
making we also of course had some big
interviews and not least with the labor
leader at Circus Dharma that we are
going to be playing you in this uh well
until 10 a.m when the rest of the news
kicks into gear so let's start off shall
we with Westminster accounts
um Sam just explained what's the
thinking about it and what did you make
of the reaction this morning
well let's start with what it is
um every politician will tell you that
the subject of money in politics is a
subject that is completely above board
because everything that they have to do
must be declared and declared publicly
and that anybody can go and look at
whether it's earnings whether it's
donations whether it's gifts all that
information is out there it's actually
in quite a lot of different places in
successive editions of the register of
members interests which is a a document
on the polo website or perhaps some of
it from the Electoral commission who
collates the information about money
that comes directly to the political
parties as opposed to individual MPS
you've got a lot of documents and
disclosure in a lot of different ways so
realistically what you're saying is if
you're a normal person wading through
all these different registers documents
looking at your MP most people are just
not going to do it I I think that's fair
to say so what we've done is we've drawn
it all together and we've done something
that is going to be quite controversial
MPS aren't going to like it I can tell
you from my phone MPS already don't like
it we have essentially put a number on a
lot of things that MPS have done we've
put a number on how much in terms of
outside the earnings they have made
since December 2019 the date of the last
general election we've done the same for
donations we've looked at donors we've
looked at some uh outside interest
groups and how they uh work together
with uh parliamentarians and now turning
the register of members Financial
interests into a spreadsheet has been a
hell of a task it's 30 people seven
months this is because the register of
members interests feels like an
incredibly dated document
um MP sitting there writing entries
almost as if by quill pen where they put
what they've earned how they've done it
in some cases where they've given the
money onto in some cases uh not but but
what that does and that context is
interesting and important and useful and
still in the public domain it went taken
away but it makes it very hard to
compare one MP with another and and that
goes to the number there that goes to
the nub of where things might get a
little bit spicy because what we've done
is assigned a single figure and then
compared MPS on a like for like basis
now MPS will tell you the information
was out there and there's lots of
context around why they do what they do
and that's all in the register too which
is fair but we think it is fair to be
able to look at who's making the largest
amount of money in outside earnings who
is getting the largest donations just in
order to to have a greater insight into
the way that money Works in politics the
bigger sums are inevitably going to be
more interesting uh right on that point
let's listen a bit to some of the
reaction that we had on the show to the
project that Sam's been talking about so
labor leadership
program I started by getting his
reaction overall to the Westminster
account project let's have a listen
transparency is a good thing I think
that you've obviously pulled together a
lot of information there made it
publicly available I think it was all in
the public domain because it's all been
declared according to we've got strong
rules as you know I think we've got some
of the strongest rules in terms of what
we have to declare but you know the more
transparency the better so everybody can
see exactly what has been declared and
ask whatever questions they want to
about it
well they go he's welcoming it uh in
general you talk there about people
being more happy to talk about the
general than the specifics yeah I I I
thought that in the scale of welcomings
that was probably muted muted medium uh
he says transparency is a good thing
more transparency uh is always a good
thing I I'm quite struck listening to
that how there was possibly a little
more defense of the status quo and an
Embrace of change and that and that
matters politically because it's
kirstama who has made one as a defining
issue really the subject of change when
it comes to the way that Westminster
Works he wants to ban second jobs
and well he made a big virtue of it at a
press conference in November 2021 that
was off the back of the Owen Patterson
Scandal Tori who was found guilty for
lobbying for cash and he did that but
but the thing is that it's a slightly
longer sentence than that there's a
rider um with very limited exceptions
and we're asking the question this
morning in the film that you played at
the start of your show whether David I'm
a David Lammy qualifies for those
limited exceptions because he does radio
work he does other uh speeches and
training and is the highest uh out has
the highest outside earnings of any MP
and what I thought was fascinating was
quite how kirst armor responded when you
asked him whether or not he agreed that
this work was one of those limited
exceptions yeah we should have a little
play of that shouldn't we uh let's
listen first shall we too uh what
happened when I specifically talked to a
case timer about David lamming
what I was proposing was
um a system for all MPS that we should
ban second jobs there's a discussion
about what exemptions there should be I
think um David for example does a lot of
media work and I think media work and
writing books is all part of the
political process but there's a
discussion to be had what I was urging
was for the whole House of Commons to
agree new rules because I do think that
we should get rid of second jobs with
some exceptions some people have jobs
where they need to top up their skills
um and I do think if you write a
political book or uh you know
yeah exactly that may be grounds for an
exemption
you see this is the key isn't it Sam you
know he's saying that we should ban
second jobs you know that it almost felt
like there was full stop at the end of
that sentence when he announced it in
the wake of the Owen Patterson Scandal
now he's talking about exceptions and
when I asked him about exemption
specifically the one he gave was
political books and I have to say it
feels to me like that's the easiest one
in the book to give right because he's
writing particularly he's got to give
that one because he's yeah writing one
as well um but the more controversial
stuff is uh is things that he's he's not
just being specific on right that's
right and and if you listen closely to
the way that kirst armor handled your
question he effectively said it was for
the House of Commons to decide the exact
rules well given that he was the person
that said there should be a ban on
second jobs with limited exemptions I I
might have thought that kirstama could
pronounce what side of the line he felt
that David lammy's outside activities
um uh fall on given that David Lammy is
Shadow foreign secretary um I have to
say what one of the activities people
might be quite relaxed about and is
David lammy's LBC job I I just I'd never
ever tell anyone not to watch site
because I use permanently but David let
me I think he's going to be on LBC maybe
as soon as 50 minutes time I mean
viewers give them a call and to be fair
um I thought the the defense that you
played in your film actually that David
Laney gave on LBC previously was
actually quite compelling you know and
for me
whether it's this topic or whether it's
almost anything that we've covered in
the Westminster accounts
I have no view on whether you know I
don't think money in politics is a bad
thing it's just a feature of life I have
no view we have no view on whether
second jobs are a good or a bad thing we
just want to understand how it works but
there is a thing that has struck me
through this which is where politicians
are prepared to engage and explain and
effectively help take voters into
understanding what's going on
particularly with money that's a good
thing for transparency and where you
have people like Theresa May where you
try and you try and you try and you try
and you try to contact them yeah and and
you fail and they know we're doing this
yeah and we keep phoning them and they
never answer I think that's where there
are questions and talking about people
who know we're doing this and answer
questions let's move on to Miracle for
shall we because you know she knew we're
going to ask about it we we pulled up
her accounts on the screen and we were
able to have a conversation going
through each one where she explained
what they were and why she was doing it
and how much she earned people will have
their own views as you say about money
in politics but the transparency has got
to be a good thing let's have a little
listen shall we to Maria Caulfield part
the money that she earned is is her work
as a nurse let's listen
but I think you know what was important
during the expenses Scandal was to try
and end uh professional politicians just
being the only route into being an MP
and so you are seeing people coming into
Westminster with outside interests I'm a
nurse I still work as a nurse I declare
those earnings on my website and then
you know cross party we have doctors who
work in the labor party uh on our side
in the conservative party and I think
it's important that people are able to
keep their interests in in that sort of
field going it certainly helps me in
terms of my work as a local constituency
MP but also as a health minister to
really see what's happening on the
ground
would you make of the Marie Crawford
interview so
um Maria Caulfield explained I thought
very eloquently why she did what she did
and mounted a uh defense of why actually
outside activities are perfectly
reasonable in in some cases and actually
I think on the case of being a nurse
Labor's case double degree the labor
exemptions to the second job ban that we
know about are nurses doctors members of
the armed services and then people who
write books and to do media appearances
and and I think they'll be a cross-party
consensus on that but that's not the
whole story it is people making large
money from uh outside organizations
particularly from speeches and from some
forms of consultancy it's important to
say Parliament has already in the last
few weeks decided to tighten its rules
there are certain types of parliamentary
advisory roles that are no longer going
to be possible maybe hitting the second
jobs of up to 30 MPS so some reforms are
underway uh but I think it's the
difficult questions are the ones that
remain Maria Caulfield talking about the
expenses Scandal this is not the
expensive scandal in fact I don't think
that there is a scandal we haven't gone
looking for a scandal and nor we found
one in the reporting this week all we
are doing is highlighting what we don't
know what we do know and then
discovering what we don't and are just
asking why not
um what should we be expecting in the
days ahead well
um not to give away any secrets
obviously well our approach has been to
look at leaderboards top tens top
hundreds so we're going to keep doing
that but it's no secret what the public
uh what the Westminster accounts what
the documents what the information tells
us it tells us not only about earnings
which we've done today it tells us about
donations it tells us about who's
getting the money and it tells us about
a little bit about these informal groups
that MPS have in Parliament all party
groups that can be supported by outside
organizations and we're looking a little
bit at that so those are the areas for
me as I say it is what we discover but
it is also what we found that we
couldn't discover that matters and it's
a conversation that's beginning there
will be a lot of angry MPS out there
today but if we can contribute to the
greater public understanding of how
money Works in politics so they don't
feel attacked the moment that the
subject comes up then that benefits
everybody
Maya's I have to say when you said that
you are already getting the sense that
MPS are not very happy with this project
yeah and and I'm not surprised about it
and I am regret that they feel that way
but would defend uh what we have done
and I think that their concern is that
we both trivialize and remove the
context of a lot of their money
um of their declarations and in some way
make it look like they're doing a bad
thing but I come back to the point that
if there is no problem with money being
in our political system then that
subject would be better neutered by
coming out and talking about why not the
most impressive MPS through the project
that we have done have been the ones
willing to engage they can make an
argument and in many cases they are
quite compelling where MPS just want to
duck and hide and sort of have a go back
that I think is where the public don't
end up understanding and start thinking
that things are shady so yes come out
criticize us
um
but what that is doing is engaging in a
discussion about how it works and that's
a good thing and that's what we're
looking to do uh fascinating and I'm
going to be watching your other reports
uh with interest as the week goes on
while we've got you it is the first show
of 2023. it's going to be a big year
isn't it we had you know big speeches
this week both from Russia student and
kirst armor are just interested in some
of your kind of political predictions I
guess what are we going to see in the
year ahead and I know you've got to take
your head out of this and put it
somewhere else I apologies so in a very
very rapid gear change there's enormous
amount of work both for Richardson
account for kissed armor to do uh this
year I mean I feel like the public
haven't quite drawn breath after last
year which was in a year like nobody has
seen in their lifetimes when it comes to
British politics and the dust hasn't
quite settled
um but we have two uh we have a prime
minister and a prime minister and a
credible Prime ministerial Contender uh
I think that kirst armor needs to set
out his vision in a way that the public
really engage with and decide that they
like he's clearly very far ahead in the
polls the question is has he sealed the
deal with Richie sunac he's got to he's
got two tasks he's got to convince the
public that he's more than a temporary
managerial front man
but also he's got a difficult task on
his hand he's got to keep his party
together because after the last seven
years really the conservative party is
in a difficult and fractured State a lot
of stories in the papers this morning
about Boris Johnson is he wearing a
comeback there are deep divisions inside
the conservative party will Boris
Johnson be the subject of this standards
inquiry you know the televised trial of
Boris Johnson
um uh where they had to decide whether
he lied will British soon act do a deal
on Northern line and that absolutely
explodes the opinion of brexiteer
members who fear that he's doing a deal
that ties us too close to the European
Union there are real landmines for him
in the coming months don't rule out a
general election this year because it
might be that those forces just aren't
able to be controlled you said that
Kirsten needs to seal the deal to prove
that he could be the next prime minister
it's been a big this week big week this
week before him he had his big speech
he's done the interview this morning on
the program do you think he's edged
closer to sealing the deal or do you
think it's we see more of the same I
think that there's been a a change from
kissed armor ever since sort of
September he got a new speechwriter
there's a new sense of confidence uh I I
you know it's interesting what happens
when it just it makes everything easier
when you're 20 points behind everything
feels more difficult and that's the
that's the world that kistama is now
operating and he looks like a big figure
on the domestic political stage when you
dig into the numbers on the polling what
what is happening a bit is that people
are losing uh losing some faith in the
conservative party a lot of those
ex-tory voters are not yet labor voters
it's that transition that he's got to
manage and hold and seal when it comes
to the next general election so there is
a job of work to be done it's really
interesting and finally the NHS because
I have to say you know whenever I speak
to people like uh you know Adrian board
on the program it's quite frightening
because they look frighten themselves
so the NHS is one of those political
issues where people make up their own
mind based on their own experience
almost every voter has or knows someone
who is engaged with the health system
and it's it isn't something you can it
isn't a problem you can spin your way
out of and that's what Richie sumac is
going to find either his Solutions make
it better or people decide that he
hasn't it hasn't worked uh fascinated
talk as always
um I hope the rest of the day goes well
the rest of the week uh you need to lie
down in a dark room after it I'm sure
and thanks very much Sam uh Coates quick
reminder our weekly podcast uh starts
again uh today there's highlights of our
interviews a bit of post-match analysis
and some insight into how we put the
program together today we'll be with
myself Scott Beasley our editor and Sam
coats subscribe wherever you get your
podcast search for safe Ridge on Sunday
it will be available again later today
uh in the meantime of course we should
be seeing you on Wednesday at the first
take we'll be back at 9 00 pm on
Wednesday great to be back have a lovely
rest of your Sunday
[Music]